my grandfather grew up with a stutter so
it kind of disabled him from
communicating maybe effectively but
that's why he was such a good listener I
feel like that really stuck with me I
wanted to make it important in my life
to be able to be a good listener he
would grew up without a father
so he had to take a lot of
responsibility he had to flee Cuba with
my grandmother my mother and my uncle in
the early sixties it's not an easy
decision to just up and leave your home
country the only place you know when the
going gets rough you just got to keep
going
you can't wallow in self-pity that
mentality is still within me or it's
like if you're not happy where you are
move my grandpa knew every clerk at the
grocery store he knew every person that
worked at his gym every single
restaurant he went to he would know the
server sometimes when I'm in like a
transactional situation and I don't have
much interest in making conversation
I'll think about my grandpa and remember
that he would totally turn anybody in
any of those situations into his friend
I feel like I learned from my grandpa
that you should try to make everyone in
your life your friend as much as
possible and that'll just lead you to be
happier everywhere you go because you'll
have a friend everywhere
she was always someone that would
distract you from whatever was keeping
you down she talked about like how she
would raise goats in Jamaica or like how
she got into a fight with this one goat
I definitely take from her my ability to
you know distract others when they're
not in the best space I always try to
tell a joke or make them think about
something happy you know I mean and not
like dwell on the negative moment I
learned that no outfit is complete
without lipstick from my grandmother and
it passed on to my mom and it passed on
to me and I'm not doing a good job my
grandmother always made you look your
best so that you could feel your best
she helped me kind of determine I guess
have a dress for life and now to you
know be ladylike hey boss he's like
giant nerf guns within the first like
ten minutes of
having it I shot my rocket on the top of
their house they're like a really dull
and I think my grandma's response is
something like well at least you were
having fun my grandparents were really
hard workers that you know kind of came
out of the depression and really built a
family and a life I think the main thing
I took away from them was just loving
people no matter where they're at in
their lives just this idea of like hey I
love you
where you're at right now and where
you're at is enough my grandma made a
kick-ass strawberry cake too she taught
me how to keep how to cook a strawberry
cake that's for sure